what is going on everybody it's
axelbeatz here for anime uproar and
today we are discussing some of the most
interesting and powerful characters in
hunter hunter hunters who are just
literally on another level these are the
stard hunters a group so exclusive that
despite the hunters association having
over 600 members we only know about 15
characters who fit into this category
before we get into this video though if
you enjoy it and you want to see more
hunter hunter content on this channel be
sure to leave a like and if you're new
here or if you just haven't subscribed
to anime uproar make this the video that
you subscribe and be sure to click that
bell for all notifications you can also
follow anime uproar on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar or you can
follow myself at excellionyt of course
this video will contain hunter hunter
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned so we all know that
to get your hunter's license you need to
pass the hunter's exam and once you do
get your hands on a license you get a
ton of benefits unlimited free access to
public services you essentially have a
passport that will let you travel
anywhere you want to pretty much openly
and you get access to a decent amount of
top secret information if you want you
can even kill just about anyone with
only a few exceptions without any
repercussions it is more or less a
license to do whatever you want to some
extent and it elevates you above
everyone else around you but this is
just the basic package i mentioned in
the intro there's a group of hunters
that are even above people who have
their hunter's license these are the
stard hunters and these stars basically
signify some level of excellence among
the already excellent general hunters
and it is a very exclusive group so i
wanted to take a look at the 16
characters that we know of who have
stars and i think it makes most sense to
start with these single star hunters the
difference between a regular license
holder and a single star hunter is that
the latter group has demonstrated some
kind of excellence in their own field
however there is often not much
information given on what that means
just that they have contributed a lot in
their field usually not really telling
us what they actually did up until now
there have been seven of them among the
characters we know of and interestingly
enough we meet one of them almost
immediately in the story being menchie
menchi was first introduced during the
hunter exam arc being one of the
examiners for the second phase she is a
gourmet hunter someone who travels the
world for rare ingredients cuisine or
food tending to be a world-class chef
however they are often called to deal
with poachers as well among the gourmet
hunters menchie is considered one of the
best and her contributions to the field
are what earned her her single star
status despite only being 21 years old
unfortunately menchie doesn't exactly
show up too much in the series so we
don't really know too much about her men
or abilities in general outside of just
being incredibly talented when it comes
to cuisine in fact it's pretty common
for the characters who have stars to not
want to show off their net abilities
most of them either seem to want to keep
them secret or hold some kind of public
office so they aren't typically out
there using their nan abilities in
battle very often another single star
hunter is cesugera he is a jackpot
hunter basically meaning he wants to
make as much money as possible through
either winning it or earning it through
contracts with the wealthy one such
contract was working with batera through
the southern peace auction to get a copy
of greed island and given that he's all
about winning prizes it makes sense that
his original goal was to complete greed
island when it comes to cesar guerra's
men we are sort of left in the dark but
not entirely while we don't directly see
his nen we do see that he is at least
very talented in ryu he is able to
easily flow his aura to any part of his
body to attain some superhuman feats
like jumping 16 meters into the air or
even just using it defensively to stop
his spine from being destroyed by one of
razer's volleyball devils that said we
also see that he has an impressive knack
for evaluating then in others and
understanding the origins and
functionality of it next up we have
morel which and this is gonna shock you
is a single star hunter whose men we
have actually seen
crazy i know he is a sea hunter meaning
he searches for treasure and animals
within the sea something which to me
would mean you're insane the sea is a
cove of nightmares and no one could
convince me otherwise we had a lot of
time with morel during the camara ant
arc where he was actually on the
extermination team he was effectively
gone and kilauea's grand mentor as he
mentored both knuckle and shoot who
helped the boys train leading towards
the chimera ant mission morel is patient
and strategic when it comes to battle
able to make plans to outsmart his
opponents and then goat them into making
mistakes as we see with both chitu and
leo speaking of morel in battle
let's talk about his nen he is primarily
a manipulator type nun user however he
is competent with enhancement emission
and transmutation making him a pretty
well-rounded character with almost all
of his abilities revolving around smoke
his main ability deep purple is
self-proclaimed to be one of the most
flexible men abilities in the world
allowing him to turn his aura into smoke
and then move and shape it freely to
create just about anything he wants he
can even change his color to make it
blend in with the environment harden it
to become nearly indestructible or
create animals and humans who are
capable of talking the possibilities are
limitless his other ability is smoky
jail creating a barrier that locks him
and his opponents inside that is
indestructible from inside or out
i gotta say the conditions to become a
single star are fairly vague and
profession specific but morel feels like
the first one with a real sense of power
to him that adds tangibility to that
title menchie is great too we see that
she's at least pretty confident in terms
of fighting but we just don't see her do
that much unfortunately next up we have
sanbika the head doctor of the hunters
association
she's a virus hunter searching for cures
solutions or new options to deal with
diseases viruses and in her case
specifically poisons
there isn't all that much to say about
her but i do really like the idea of
having someone in the field as important
as medicine being given a star in the
association having a skill set that
specifically helps humanity seems to be
much more relevant to me than something
like jackpot hunting so i definitely
appreciate seeing that here bushidora
the blacklist hunter who focuses on
bounty hunting or hunting dangerous
criminals has a role in the story that
is quite literally short-lived but
throughout the time we have with him he
was steadfast in promoting morality in
the hunters association he was a member
of the pure paladin squad and
specifically worked towards creating a
better set of bylaws for hunters he
namely had an issue with bylaw number
four which restricted hunters from
targeting other hunters until they have
done something awful he was the typical
justice needs to act first kind of
archetype however hisoka quickly dealt
with him the last two single star
hunters are kinda blank sheets ich
shanpei was a hacker hunter someone who
was very well versed in computers and
the internet who has made an impact on
cyber crime and the worst character on
this list
cutie beauty is a cute hunter who tries
to stay beautiful and keep her youthful
age
she is
extremely creepy in my opinion and i
have never been so happy to not have
information on a character
moving on to the double star hunters
just like the single star they have to
have done something phenomenal in their
respective fields however they also have
a few extra criteria they have to also
meet the expectations of the first six
points of the punters bylaws which
depending on the translation are called
the hunter commandments which to me is a
much cooler name so that's what i'm
gonna go with but that's just my correct
opinion the relevant commandments are
one hunters must always be on the hunt
for something two hunters need a minimal
understanding of martial arts including
men
3. once they are licensed that license
cannot be taken away for any reason
that said the hunter license cannot be
reissued if lost for any reason
even if the hunter's license is lost
though they still will be classified as
a hunter nothing can change that 4
hunters shall not target other hunters
unless they commit heinous crimes 5. one
star is given to hunters who produce
remarkable achievement in their fields
and 6 two stars are given to hunters who
fulfill the five actions mentioned and
who have mentored a junior hunter who is
awarded a star luckily the first three
commandments are just kind of freebies
for most hunters and the fourth is just
don't kill other hunters so really the
second star is more about showing that
you can be a leader for the next
generation that said based on how few
people get stars in general mentoring
another hunter to the point that they
get a star as well
is pretty impressive we only know six
double star hunters at this point so we
should probably start with the one we're
most familiar with with biscuit she is a
stone hunter which as the name suggests
involves her looking for precious gems
and stones what is interesting is that
despite biscuit being a double star
hunter and having met a few of her
students namely gon kilauea and wing
none of the students we know have a star
meaning that she has another unnamed
student who is a single star hunter
actually looking at the list of double
star hunters that we know it doesn't
seem that we know any of their students
who are single star so we have all these
characters who were mentors but we don't
know who their students were that
achieve this honor biscuit is kind of a
jerk when she first meets gon and
kilauea she actively tries to drive them
apart and in general she can be very
manipulative to get what she wants even
choosing to appear as a child despite
being 57 and using her cutesy appearance
to get people to think that she's very
innocent she is famously a chronic liar
however once she gets to know someone
more closely she is a powerful and loyal
ally to have speaking of power let's
talk about her nan biscuit is a
transmuter but she also is talented as
an emitter enhancer and manipulator
regularly practicing in all five
learnable forms of men and in general
she's just very knowledgeable about men
making her a perfect person to teach
others
even if her methods are a bit excessive
at times her abilities include magical
spa service through which she creates a
masseuse named cookie which uses
massages to revitalize people remove
excess fat and cure a decent number of
muscle or bone related maladies she can
also use piano massage an ability that
allows 30 minutes of sleep to be
equivalent to 8 hours super effective
when you're trying to make the most of
your training time and like i just want
to take a moment to mention how these
two abilities are basically the perfect
things to have in the real world sure
there are other ones that are better for
like situational things but imagine just
like oh my back is sore boom there's a
masseuse i'm extremely tired boom 30
minutes becomes a whole night's rest
these are phenomenal and i wish i had
them in my life her most commonly used
ability though is body transformation
allowing her to swap between her normal
jojo's bizarre adventure-esque body to a
young girl's body while this does reduce
her power it also lets her be cuter and
hide her true strength which is pretty
useful for her following biscuit we have
jing
and although he is a double star he
could technically apply to be a triple
star if he wanted jing is a ruin hunter
someone who is basically an
archaeologist seeking to restore and
revive ancient civilizations however
more importantly he is the worst like
just the worst what an awful person and
terrible dad
actually i think i need to watch him
getting hit real quick
okay one more
one more
all right that's enough
one more
okay okay when it comes to jing's
abilities what is probably his most
impactful factor is his innate talent
and intuition for example he claims he
can copy any punching ability after
being struck with it once quickly being
able to understand how it works and then
replicate it for example he copied
leorio's remote punch
all right last time i swear
and this intuition actually extends
beyond being able to copy it actually
being able to tell what kind of men
people specifically use after seeing
them use their skill similar to
biscuit's understanding of nen
practically jing seems to be innately
aware of the theory side of nen for
example learning remote punch he adapted
it further into ultrasound which can be
used to detect what is hiding within or
behind something i think both of these
characters exemplify the difference
between a one and two star character in
that way there's just a little bit
something extra in how they understand
nen that just continues to elevate them
jing's final ability that we've seen is
phasing bullets by putting his hands
onto something he can shoot aura beams
or bullets through them which is very
useful in tandem with ultrasound next up
we have a member of the zodiac with a
double star crime hunter in misestom i
definitely mispronounced that i am sorry
crime hunters as the name suggests hunt
criminals mizei stomp tends to be a much
less active member and prefers to work
behind the scenes as an intelligence
supplying kind of character or in
running things like the police force he
is often referred to as the conscience
of the zodiacs trying to keep people
within a very strict set of morals for
example we see him being very vocal
about his concerns with the v6 being
such a small group in the world that
controls so much of the planet now what
can he actually do well this is one of
the few cases in hunter hunter that
shows a really fun twist on a
character's design which is then tied
into their abilities themes as his
costume is based on a cow he visually
has a very black and white theme and as
such his nan revolves around referee
cards if he shows a blue card people are
admitted to enter an area yellow will
briefly restrain them and red will expel
them it's kind of fun and while this
might not be the most powerful on paper
we see that he is at least strong enough
to be a sparring partner for netero
which speaks for itself another two star
zodiac member is sacho who might have my
least favorite character design in the
entire series he is a double star
problem hunter something we don't really
know the specifics of sacho is very
calculated and that's kind of just his
entire role in the series he's someone
who looks at everything from a very
realistic view and while we don't know
much about his powers based on his
design i think it's probably safe it has
something to do with swordsmanship but
that is just a guess tara dane is a
double star headhunter which rather than
being someone who kills people like the
title might suggest he's actually more
of a talent scout he was also the leader
of the pure paladin squad who was aiming
to reform the group however he was
killed alongside bushidora by hisoka and
unable to do so our last double star is
lynnet someone who we know very little
about aside from the fact that she's a
very small old woman who was good
friends with netero she was also a
gourmet hunter similar to menchie and
with those out of the way we can get
into the big ones the triple star
hunters of the over 600 hunters in the
association only about 10 of them have
made it to this point and of those 10 we
only know three after becoming a single
star hunter by demonstrating excellence
in your field and mentoring another
person to do so themselves triple star
hunters then went on to have remarkable
achievement in other fields as well it
isn't enough to be a master of one topic
anymore you need to be able to show that
you are among the best of the best in
everything you do which is probably why
every triple star hunter that we know
either is or was a member of the zodiac
again just a reminder jing could be a
triple star if he wanted to alright so
first off we have botobay gigante a
triple star terrorist hunter which as
the title suggests hunts down terrorists
and acts to prevent their attacks
this also means that he has a pretty
good understanding of the military law
and politics between nations this
combined with his powerful sense of
loyalty and ability to stay calm in most
situations that don't involve person
make him a very integral part in the
hunter association's role in the story
the most important thing that he really
offers to society though is that he acts
towards getting the zodiac members to
cooperate with one another even if he
isn't always successful in this
unfortunately as is the case with many
of the political characters we just
don't know what he can do as far as his
men as i mentioned most of them tend to
hide their abilities to the point that
even when periston is about to see
jing's ability he seems very surprised
that he would share his technique
cheadle yorkshire is a triple star
disease hunter similar to sanvika that
said something to notice is that zombika
was the head doctor of the hunters
association and is outranked by cheatle
this doesn't exactly mean that cheadle
is more talented as a doctor or even in
their specific field but it does mean
that cheadle outranks zambika due to
having a more widespread skill set
cheadle is currently the chairman of the
association following in netero's
footsteps after he died technically
following in periston's footsteps but
you know what i mean she is incredibly
smart and has a great moral compass
making her a perfect fit for leadership
in the association something that i
really appreciate about her character is
her ability to understand the reality of
a situation and the modesty that's tied
to that despite not being a big fan of
pearson she can still recognize that he
has aspects about himself that surpass
her and respects those traits even if
she isn't always happy about them and
capping out our list of the highest
ranked known hunters is pariston hill a
triple star hunter who is the first in
the video that we don't know which field
he's in what is interesting is that with
other characters like cheadle we know
that she's both a doctor and a lawyer so
at least we know what kind of fields she
focused on but with harrison all we know
is that he was the 12th vice chairman
and that he was the 13th chairman of the
association that's kind of it pearston
is a very playful and sneaky person he
doesn't care about winning or losing so
long as he's having fun couple into this
the fact that he's a genius and you have
an absolute menace of a human being he
very much reminds me of hisoka in a way
where he's sort of a force of chaos only
interested in his own entertainment or
goals
this is also kind of funny because they
share a voice actor in hiroki takahashi
between the adaptations but i'd say that
person is more of a chaotic neutral
character he isn't really a bad guy per
se but he is just kind of a dickling he
states that he's happy when people hate
him and that he wants to hurt the things
that he cares about something that he
thinks makes him very similar to jing we
don't really know too much about how
strong pearson is as a person or what
his nan is but we do know that he was
another one of netro's sparring partners
however he claims that he is very weak
at the same time he later calls out jing
for underestimating him so he's sending
a ton of mixed messages
based on who he is as a character though
i think we could probably believe that
he's actually decently powerful not the
most powerful especially physically but
i'm sure there is much more to him than
he wants us to believe i could see him
having a very sneaky form of nen which
could tip the scales in his favor
throughout the battle and one last thing
that i wanted to bring up before ending
the video is someone who i think should
at least be included quickly being isaac
netero while there is no reference to
netero being a triple star hunter there
could obviously be an argument made that
he could have been won the entire time
as he's said to be one of the greatest
hunters in history of course he was the
12th chairman but to play devil's
advocate that doesn't exactly mean he
had to be a triple star hunter either
because of the system that's in place he
could have just never applied for the
upgrade like jing did or it could have
just been the case that he never
mentored a single star hunter directly
to get his second star and he might have
just never reached outside of his given
field remember it isn't a power system
directly it's more about hitting very
specific achievements even if someone
was the strongest hunter that doesn't
really mean they have to do those things
required to get stars and just because
he's chairman doesn't really mean
anything to become chairman all he
really needed to do was to win in votes
again nothing to do with stars for
example in the 13th election leorio was
in the running for chairman almost the
entire time even being in first place in
the eighth round despite not having even
a single star to his name so yes metro
is absolutely worth mentioning as he is
incredibly powerful and important but
that isn't exactly enough to get a star
in the first place let alone three i
just thought this is something that we
might want to cover as most people are
pretty interested in netro and likely
would have asked where he was on this
list but that wraps up all of our
starred hunters i think it is really
interesting that this entire system is
entirely separate to their own personal
power unfortunately it means that we
don't really know much about many of
their net abilities what is also
interesting to me is that there's such a
wide array of hunter fields that people
can delve into which raises the question
what kind of hunter would you be
personally i think i would be a ruin
hunter even if i think that jing is a
garbage person i do love the
archaeologist aspect of it i went to
school for history so i just think
that's pretty in line with what i would
like but what would you be let me know
in the comments down below and if you
guys enjoyed this hunter hunter video
and want to see more videos like it
remember to leave a like and if you're
new to anime uproar remember to
subscribe and ring that bell to select
all notifications by doing this you can
guarantee that you will not miss any
future videos and of course you can also
follow anime uproar at anime uproar on
twitter and instagram or myself at
excellionyt
i wanna give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thanks to
alpha sigma who is an absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twigo himself and
of course are the one tier patrons the
ones who rise above all other clans
these being ingrata patahepha al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted chi the
spike 8227 dylan isadore spidey life
tennelle tungsten tarcus baked buddhist
and monkey d quilly and finally thank
you to all of our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven angel cruise rathuen de ora
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia ted not ted fatboy games
corey mcgowan and soul ray slice and
dice if you enjoy our videos and feel
like they provide some kind of value to
you please consider checking out our
patreon through the link in the
description anyone who supports the
channel with even a single dollar has
access to our exclusive patreon only
discord and your name will appear at the
end of videos just like all of these
phenomenal people but for now i want to
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time remember to stay active
[Music]
bye